haben wir was ist mit dir was steffen
viel scheiß fragen ja sagt er ehrlich
das war doch mal kommen um chris bourque
okay wenn ich eine freundin sieht ja
jetzt im interview abonnieren nicht
in die lage die lage ist gut die lage
stabil das wird das nicht so schön aber
sonst geht es mir gut ok neues album
öffentlich das zweite ist es und es
läuft glaube ich nicht so ganz schlecht
ist cool auf jeden fall die resonanzen
sind sehr stabil sehr erfreulich wir
sind auf elf rennen gegangen in den
charts so waren auch noch in der zweiten
woche sogar in den charts sind der
schweiz auch auf 17 gechartet österreich
sind auch gechartet also man merkt auf 5
es geht nach vorne wir sind zufrieden
und guter dinge
woran das erste album das ja schon eine
weile her das ist noch immer irgendwo
weiterhin wirklich das war das war
überhaupt nicht vergleichbar ich glaube
wir waren jetzt mit diesem album in der
zweiten woche sogar noch stärker als wir
damals mit dem ersten album überhaupt in
der ersten woche waren von daher merkt
man dass wir auf jeden fall unsere
arbeit gut tun und die leute auf jeden
fall interessiert an der musik sind wir
haben sehr viel live gespielt letztes
jahr nach dem album das erste und man
merkt auf jeden fall dass wir stetig
wachsen und gesund wachsen und das ist
unser hauptziel du gehst jetzt auch
direkt wieder auf tour weder direkt gas
geben weder die leute auf jeden fall an
fixen wir haben auf jeden fall ne geile
tour also eine geile show ausgearbeitet
wir sind gespannt wie es drohe also wie
es bei den leuten ankommt weil das auch
die erste tour die zu einem stück spiele
und auch die erste große wirklich so zu
sagen und ich bin auf jeden fall guter
dinge und die leute sollten vorbeikommen
und sich selber ein bild machen wie es
funktioniert ok
bevor diese seen stattgefunden hat und
bevor ich deine neue dein neues album
gehört habe dachte ich mein gott jetzt
höre ich schon ich bin jetzt du weißt
ich bin jetzt nicht der musikexperte
auch der rap experte aber ich habe so
viele texte gehört wo sich immer nur
darum gedreht ich ich ich bin der beste
der tollste links und dachte jetzt redet
sich aber langsam kreis bei dir ist es
nicht ganz so ist das bewusst deine
richtung oder wohin geht der deutsche
web also ich glaub der deutsche web
entwickelt sich allgemein in sehr
facettenreiche richtung gerade so da
gibt es tausende rapper wo ich sagt die
sind einfach schrott aber es gibt auch
im moment wirklich gute leute die
einfach ihr ding machen kann ob ich die
musik und gut finde oder nicht gut finde
aber man merkt ihr einfach auch daran
was die leute bereit sind das zu
unterstützen dass die leute die sich auf
jeden fall
entweder finden sei es jetzt ob
derjenige darüber rappt wie andere
mütter massakriert aber sei es darum
dass es darum geht dass die leute das
gut finden beziehungsweise sich selbst
wiederfinden ihr eigenes leben so dass
es eigentlich mein hauptaspekt in der
musik und man merkt einfach dass man
nicht nur im deutschen rap herumkommt so
ist man kann das alles versuchen tod zu
reden aber wenn man sich einfach fakten
und zahlen anguckt muss man sich am ende
des tages eingestehen wenn das auch
nicht da vielleicht wahrscheinlich nicht
deine musik ist oder seine musik ist
oder ihre musik ist es ist trotzdem
musik die respektiert werden muss
genauso wie jeder andere auch okay und
wahnsinnige abrufzahlen reich und schön
hat nach sechs tagen aber jetzt wieviel
ab 1,5 millionen wagen dann auf jeden
fall heftig und wir sind auch selber
überrascht weil so krass war es jetzt
noch nie aber man merkt er daran wie der
hype gerade funktioniert und bei uns war
es wirklich so dass wir gesagt haben wir
wollen uns nicht so in den vordergrund
drängen und wir müssen jetzt überall da
sein und immer am lautesten und das
größte stück vom kuchen haben wir haben
gesagt was muss unsere arbeit machen
dass die gut machen so und den leuten
das geben so beziehungsweise das
bestmögliche was überhaupt uns rausholen
können und das haben wir erreicht so wir
sind jetzt gerade dabei das wir sagen
okay jetzt sind wir doppelt so motiviert
wie vor weil wir jetzt sind das ist bei
den leuten ankommt den leute interesse
wohin geht dann du sagst facettenreich
aber wohin geht der trend wenn ich sehe
haftbefehl ist genauso der neue heiße
scheiß wie du aber eigentlich sind es
zwei verschiedene richtungen sind schon
auf jeden fall zwei verschiedene
richtung aber man kann glaube ich keinen
keinen trend fest machen wohin musik
geht also beziehungsweise wohin
deutscher rap geht ist es eher so dass
man sich seine eigene nische aufbauen
muss und die leute sind mittlerweile
bereit zuzuhören daher sage ich mal hat
jeder die möglichkeit seine eigene
nische aufzubauen sich dort zu
etablieren und sich für sein eigenes
standing so gerade zu machen so ob der
ein jetzt darüber ab ob der andere
darüber das spielt für mich am ende des
tages keine rolle ich trete keinem
respektlos gegenüber so nur weil etwas
anderes macht als ich so und von daher
denke ich persönlich ich kann keinen
trend ausmachen ich kann nur mehr ich
merke einfach nur dass die jugend sehr
interessiert an rap wieder ist und auch
mittlerweile sehr bereit ist ihre
eigenen künstler die sie gut finden zu
unterstützen damit die ganze sache noch
gesunder wächst ich glaube ist bei den
leuten angekommen dass musik ein
kostenloses gutes hast du das
vorhergesehen dass es bei dir mal so
laufen könnte also ich habe immer daran
geglaubt ich musste aber ich würde jetzt
lügen wenn ich sagen würde ich hatte
immer gute zeiten ich habe für meinen
traum sag ich mal nicht im moment leben
darf natürlich viele rückschläge
erlitten ich habe teilweise bevor es der
hype losging musste ich auch zu sehen
dass ich noch irgendwie ganz normal über
die runden kommen also gemacht ganz
normal wie man im leben wie jeder der
sein leben nach geht so ich habe hass
ist sozusagen ja okay weil so weniger
autos gewaschen oder ich hab keine autos
gewaschen aber autos liegt schon ganz
nah ich habe viele sachen gemacht ich
habe auch nur ausbildung gemacht als der
spannungs mechaniker ich habe wie du
gerade das ein bisschen im auto herum
gefährden ich habe die ist und das
gemacht so kleinigkeiten die angefallen
sind ich bin jemand ich bin flexibel was
anfällt bin ich bereit ist zu machen
solange school für mich ist okay
du hast aber auch man ganz anderen weg
eingeschlagen du wolltest mal fußballer
wäre richtig ich also mein
kindheitstraum war fußballer aber
deshalb nicht so in erfüllung gegangen
wie ich mir vorgestellt habe aber das
leid nicht nur in meiner hand das lag
einfach den umständen entsprechen dass
sich ein autounfall hatte schien
wadenbeinbruch eine maschine im bein
nach einem jahr schiene wieder raus viel
reha keinen anschluss mehr gefunden
musik helfen mir bitte ok aber
wenn du sagst du hattest viele
rückschläge warum macht man dann weiter
das ist eine gute frage warum macht man
weiter man hat einen traummann hat ein
ziel vor augen so dass es gibt man nicht
einfach so aus der hand ich weiß nicht
ob es in anderen sachen auch so ist aber
wenn man von etwas angefixt ist
beziehungsweise etwas vor augen hat dann
will man das auch erreichen so und da
findet man vieles in kauf so ich hätte
ich kann dir sagen das hätte ich mich
die letzten drei jahre mit anderen
sachen beschäftigt hätte ich
wahrscheinlich in den letzten zwei
jahren vielleicht mehr geld verdienen
dadurch aber da ich jetzt sehe dass wo
ich angekommen bin dann habe ich doch
alles richtig gemacht weil es ist nicht
immer es geht nicht nur immer ums geld
natürlich muss man sein kühlschrank voll
haben der soll nicht leer stehen abends
und magen knurren so das habe ich auch
durch gemacht da muss ich ganz ehrlich
sein so aber es geht darum dass man das
macht was man liebt das ist natürlich
oft schwer und nicht immer vereinbar mit
dem leben weil andere vielleicht andere
umstände eher nötig sind ich kann es
jetzt nicht so genau so verallgemeinern
für jeden menschen und jede person aber
es gibt halt wirklich darum glücklich zu
sein in dem was man tut und wie man das
macht so was sind die übrigens das
lustige ist ich war jetzt auf eine messe
berufe live
geht es ja darum kann man sich
informieren was kann man also gerufen
und das sind ja auch skills man muss was
ich machen woran man spaß an aber jetzt
zum rappen was muss man haben damit man
erstens durchhält und zweitens damit man
auch sein ziel erreicht also worauf
jedenfalls sehr viel ehrgeiz man darf
sich nicht entmutigen lassen und man
braucht auf jeden fall einen gesunden
denn ich leider nicht bei leuten der
kenner einen gesunden menschenverstand
also nicht bei allen brettern sagen wir
mal über so dass man es realistisch zu
sich selber ist und ich war einfach
immer realistisch zu mir selber ich habe
mir die anderen sachen angeht und hab
gesagt ich kann das besser und dann
mache ich es einfach besser so natürlich
ging das nicht von heute auf morgen es
war ein training so ist wie jeder beruf
auch ich mein wenn man geht ja nicht
umsonst als beispiel ein 17-jähriger
irgendwo in die lehre man kann das als
25-jähriger vielleicht sagen jetzt
beherrscht ich meinen job wirklich sehr
gut ich kenne das kleine einmaleins ich
weiß links rechts ist dieser handgriff
so ist das mit rap nicht viel anders so
natürlich ist aber bei web eine sache
man muss schon einen gewissen
grundvoraussetzung von talent mitbringen
wenn man die nicht erfüllt kein gutes
gespür für den musik hat und so dann ist
es schon schwierig dann habe ich schon
oft auch so irgendwelche grobmotoriker
erlebt dann halt wirklich zehn jahre
dabei sind und immer noch nicht den weg
finden so also man sollte schon viele
verschiedene aspekte berücksichtigen
denke ich weiß wenn man diese musik
musik machen will okay aber gesagt dass
gerade man muss es können man muss
wissen man muss einen gesunden menschen
nahmen aber ich sage mal auch jemand der
es nicht kann denkt der verzicht davon
daran sonst games endlich die
grobmotoriker wiegen dass also das
traurige an dieser musik also
beziehungsweise ein rap musik so aber
ich denke er ist bei popmusik wie man
bei den ganzen tasten show sieht nicht
viel anders es gibt viele idioten auf
dieser welt solange es menschen gibt die
idioten sind das kann ich nicht
verändern und kein anderer kann das
verändern und ich möchte das auch gar
nicht so herr abwertend klingen aber in
bezug auf fähigkeiten muss man einfach
vielleicht auch noch sein freundeskreis
wird oder vielleicht objektive meinung
an sich ranlassen dann wird man schon
die wahrheit schnell erkennen wenn man
ehrlich zu sich selber ist okay du sagst
man muss was können rhytmus waren thema
deutsche sprache ist es auch wie ich
würde jetzt sag mal sagen in den raum
geworfen man muss in deutsch eigentliche
1 haben und gut retten zu können das
stimmt
zumindest
ich hatte unglaubliche 3 oder ja eine
gute 3 hatte ich einmal den deutsch ich
habe mich aber auch schatten der 404
tatsache
ich war in mathe da für mich so gut also
ich denke es liegt nicht daran dass man
jetzt sage ich mal dieses schulbildung
gut mitbekommen hat wobei die natürlich
auch wichtig ist aber
ich sag mal so in der schule lernt man
ja nicht unbedingt
sachen die fürs leben sag ich mal
wichtig sind man lernt dinge die einen
geschmack eine gewisse bildung
verschaffen um in der zukunft vielleicht
auf gewisse schwierigkeiten verzichten
zu können wie zum beispiel ich weiß das
klingt total weit hergeholt aber es ist
ja möglich kommen ja aus einem land wo
das noch aktuell ist zum beispiel dass
manche menschen analphabeten einfach
sind so und mit den kleinsten dingen im
leben nicht zurecht kommen das ist ja
schon etwas sage ich mal was die schulen
vermitteln man kriegt ein allgemeiner
allgemeinbildung einen gewissen grad an
allgemeinbildung vermittelt den man auch
benötigt im alltag so beziehungsweise
überhaupt und gesellschaftsfähig zu sein
aber sage ich mal so dinge wie
kreativität war meiner meinung nach in
der schule immer fehl am platz so wenn
einer irgendwie aus der reihe tanzt ist
der muss aussortiert vor die tür
gestellt und da bleibst du jetzt so das
war manchmal glaube ich selber auch sein
kann wieder soweit mir ist so langweilig
ich weiß nicht ich saß einfach im
unterricht ich hatte einen 60-jährigen
politik lehrer und das ist so trocken
runtergebracht dass ich mir einfach am
kopf gefasst habe und einfach nicht
still sitzen konnte es war einfach zu
langweilig für mich nichtsdestotrotz bin
ich ein sehr interessierter mensch eine
politik also kann man mal sehen das sind
irgendwie so widersprüchliche sachen so
okay was gerade gesagt
gesellschaftsfähig würde man da lernen
hast du das gelernt was denn
gesellschaftsfähig zu sein ich habe das
von zu hause aus gelesen also ich mein
vater meine mutter hat immer sehr viel
wert darauf gelegt dass sich im manieren
beigebracht kriege sprich älteren
gegenüber respektvoll benehme nicht wie
ein vollidiot durch die gegend rennen
aber in der studio konzert von ich mich
zurückgehalten da muss das manchmal oder
des öfteren mal raus ich war wirklich
ein bisschen verrückt in der schulzeit
ich glaube meine lehrer erinnern sich
nur ungern haben mich zurück auch nur
ungern an die zurück aber es waren halt
nichtsdestotrotz eine lehrreiche zeit
und ich habe auch trotz alldem da auch
obwohl ich ein clown war im unterricht
habe ich trotzdem als schulabschluss
gemacht das soll nicht so darstellen als
ob ich irgendwie dann komplett neben der
reihe stand zu ich meine eltern haben
darauf schon auf jeden fall wert gelegt
und sie haben mir beigebracht wenn du
ähnlich stillsitzen kannst du scheiße
war's dann musst du wenigstens lernen
und etwas für die schule tun ist jetzt
auch keine besondere leistung einen
realschulabschluss nur und dass man zu
allen nur zu unterstreichen dass ich
dann nicht so komplett drauf geschissen
haben und das sollten die leute oder
beziehungsweise in meinen jüngeren
zuhörer sich auch vor augen halten dass
wir in deutschland leben und hier
einfach ganz klar leute auf dem zeugnis
achten so ein arbeitgeber kennt dich
nicht erkennt nicht deine sympathie der
weiß nicht wo du herkommst ob du ihnen
das und das fähig bist er guckt als
erstes auf dem zeugnis wenn du dich
bewirbst und da solltest du einigermaßen
versuchen zu glänzen so zumindest in den
fächern in denen du gut bist du solltest
herauskristallisieren ok und später im
beruf hast du da das sofort hingekriegt
wenn du gesagt hast dich richtig zu
verhalten oder hast du das nicht
umschalten kann ich bin also ich bin ein
sehr umgänglicher typ und meine meister
das hatte ich auch wirklich das glück
die haben sehr schnell gemerkt dass ich
jemand bin der mann alles auftragen kann
aber den ton muss bei mir stimmt und da
hat man mit mir kein problem sondern
kommt man sehr gut mit mir zurecht und
die haben halt einfach gemerkt dass ich
wenn es darum geht so der laute ton oder
der befehls und da bin ich sehr sensibel
und das haben sie sehr stellen aber auch
herauskristallisiert und haben dann eine
eigene art entwickelt wie die mit mir
trotzdem gut umgehen können und ich habe
dann auch alles gerne gemacht sowas muss
man der liebesbrief frei wenn man was
heute mit mal eben was man muss auf
jeden fall den ton treffen okay du hast
gesagt du interessiert sich für politik
und deine texte sind ja auch so dass man
eben sagt da ist was inhalt drin
möchtest du was verändern also ich
möchte verändern im sinne von was kann
nicht verändern das soll so die frage
sein bzw die schon richtig die
freiwilligen aber dann stelle ich mir
die frage was kann ich während ich kann
meiner generation meinen zuhörern den
leuten die meine musik mögen kann ich
nur etwas versuchen den kopf zu bewirken
was am ende des tals daraus resultiert
weiß ich nicht aber zum beispiel die
arbeiten die ich tun kann mit meinen
gegebenen möglichkeiten sind sachen wie
workshops mit jugendlichen wenn ich zum
beispiel bei uns in der stadt war vor
kurzem noch einer leider hat er dann
wird er dann auch gekündigt weil er
überall in jugendhäusern geld gestrichen
wird wenn streetworker und da hat mich
dann teilweise wirklich in seinem bulli
gepackt und komm mit mir mit thoma
einmal diesen gefallen ich habe ja klar
warum nicht ich fühle mich da nicht
irgendwie jetzt privilegiert dass ich
das nicht mehr machen kann und das ist
das was ich leisten kann ich kann ich
kann nicht im bundestag reden und sagen
hören wir jetzt alle zu schmeißen mich
da raus und packen mit dem bnd für ein
jahr lang wechsel das ist einfach so und
man muss auch einfach mal realistisch
sein die politik in deutschland spricht
einfach so eine hässliche sprache ist es
nicht nur in deutschland so ist das
allgemein ein phänomen einem menschen
fremde sprache ein 16 jähriger der vor
den fans aus versehen bei phoenix
einschaltet und die bundestagsdebatte
mit bekommt er versteht kein wort von
dem was da geredet wird ich selbst habe
schwierigkeiten dem zu folgen was da
gesagt wird und im endeffekt wenn
hässliche sachen sehr schön geredet und
der mensch weiß eigentlich gerade gar
nicht worum es da geht so und das finde
ich herzlich an politik und auch ein
bisschen dieses verlogene dieses ganze
in zürich also das ist so dass ich sage
ich bin ein sehr interessierter politik
ein mensch aber umso mehr man sich damit
beschäftigt umso deutlicher werden diese
ganzen hässlichen kleinen lügen die
einen das so die die tränen in die augen
treiben auf gut deutsch gesagt so wo man
sagt okay dass das seid ihr und ich bin
hier so was soll ich jetzt ändern was
was hat ihr am ende aber uns dann später
vorwerfen werden falsche vorbilder oder
wir würden uns nicht benehmen die
jugendwehr eine party generation und
sonst hier immer nur eine große klappe
haben unsere politiker und am ende des
tages kommt auch nicht viel bei rum gut
wenn ich aber jetzt dann höre was bei
einer autogrammstunde von dna passiert
ist dann würden die politiker sagen wie
du siehst du doch die harmonie sind ding
du musst es mit der polizei rausgeholt
werden weil es anders nicht mehr gegen
die glasscheiben gingen zu bruch
verletzte letztlich auch bei haftbefehl
das scheint ja irgendwie bei euch üblich
zu sein dass einfach so dass die dass
der andrang sehr groß war sodann war
keiner feindselig das war ja das dingen
so und die polizei war auch total
überfordert also dann wenn ich jetzt ich
will ja gar nicht ins detail gehen die
haben sich benommen teilweise da dachte
ich mir oh mein gott wo habt ihr eure
ausbildung bekommen so
ich wurde hinter sogar ein schnitt von
einem dieser beamten als ob ich daran
schuld wäre so der km rennen schreibt
ist einfach schreiben sprechen gerade an
redet man normal mit mir was redest du
denn wer bist du überhaupt ich kenne ich
nicht so und man muss mit respekt in
oyten gegenübertreten und dieser
polizist hatte wohl das gefühl er wäre
es zu höherem berufen oder wenn was
besseres und ich haben klipp und klar
deutlich gemacht so redest du nicht mit
mir egal ob du eine uniform an hast du
hast mit respekt mit mir zu reden du
bist die ausführende gewalt so weite und
meer bist du auch nicht und du kannst
hier nicht hinkommen und sich offen als
wenn du ihr der präsident der
vereinigten staaten werden gehört alles
was du siehst benimm dich die
jugendlichen sind bisschen euphorisch
gewesen die haben bisschen gedrängelt
die türsteher waren auch überfordert so
was passiert zum glück ist nichts
ernsthaftes passiert für die leichten
blessuren die dann ein bisschen davon
getragen und tut es mir leid aber daran
sieht man ja dass wir etwa im gegensatz
zu vielen anderen popsternchen die
sicher dass ihre nase irgendwo im
horizont rang immer noch die mühe machen
und versuchen unseren fans nahe zu sein
so wir machen das ja nicht weil wir
daran geld verdienen denn zu einer
autogrammstunde
beispielhaft saß ich fünf stunden in
weiterstadt einfach auf einem stuhl hat
autogramme geschrieben weil der andrang
so groß meinte auch der geschäftsführer
zu mir ich habe das schon oft erlebt
dass hier künstler gekommen sind nicht
mal die hälfte los waren sich schon nach
einer halben stunde stunde abgebrochen
haben weil die schnauze voll haben aber
wie rapper wir sind bodenständig geht
sehr gut sehr gut
wir hatten das letztlich mit culcha
candela geht es um integration und das
ich eben auch eigentlichen
deutsche-bank-chef integrieren sollte du
hast gerade das beispiel von polizisten
genannt ist mangelnder respekt ein
generelles problem und sollte
das ist eine gute frage ob das
mangelnder respekt ist wieder mangelnde
mangelndes miteinander aber das ist das
ein jahr nicht aus ich denke schon dass
mangelnder respekt voreinander schon das
grundproblem ist und das würde ich auch
so unterstreichen im sinne von ich kann
mich nicht findet für den anderen ich
interessiere mich nicht für den anderen
ich kann mich nicht in den anderen seine
situation hineinversetzen
ich bin das non-plus-ultra alles was
danach kommt kommt lange nichts dann
kommt wieder ich dann kommt lange wieder
nichts dann kommt wieder ich so
verhalten sich halt viele mitbürger und
das führt zu nichts so war aber das ist
auch ein thema so dann könnte man sich
stundenlange die köpfe mit einschlagen
so ich sehe was ihr auch im deutschen
fernsehen in die massen getankt wird und
dann da braucht man sich nicht wundern
wenn viele menschen einfach so
schulten mäßig durch die gegend rennen
ich habe keinen bock auf das deutsche
fernsehprogramm ich krieg das kalte
kotzen dabei sei es von rtl das
mittagsprogramm bis hin zum zdf markus
lanz der liner sitzt und seine gäste
versucht fortzuführen so also das alles
für mich so es gibt natürlich gute
sender und was heißt gut zu sein als
gutes sendung ich mir gerne anschaue und
auch interessant finde aber man sollte
schon auf jeden fall die spreu vom
weizen trennen so dass viel schrott bei
als ich recherchiert habe zu dir man
guckt immer bei wikipedia rheins das
wort ja aber was auch nein er ist so
glatt nein die gegner jugendlich aber
als ich fahrt ein leben habe ja dann
kommt als erster wunsch stelle kommt
eine übersetzung was das heißt und das
heißt göttliche pflicht hast du da eine
verbindung zu seinem überhaupt nicht am
ryder dann muss ich an dieser stelle
musste ich das auch mal wirklich
klatschen ich bin ein gläubiger mensch
das spielt keine rolle so unabhängig
davon ein echter name ist fahrrad also
fhdw und dafür meinen kollegen war es
einfach irgendwann als wir jünger war
einfach viel zu lange genauso wie ganz
schnell mal aus anderen namen an andere
künstler aus daniela wird man schnell
daniel roth aus fahrrad einfach fad und
ich habe das früher nicht so
wahrgenommen dass ich das jetzt
unbedingt um ändern muss um den
künstlernamen geben muss ich habe
einfach dennoch vaart ich nehme ich doch
eh so dann bleibe ich auch so und im
nachhinein habe ich festgestellt wie
viele bedeutung ist dafür gibt im
arabischen beziehungsweise bei den
libanesen heißt es waffe auf französisch
heißt es schminke also ist 1000
millionen übersetzungen ich habe
persönlich keine übersetzung dafür will
nano gimmicks fab okay aber es hätte ja
sein können dass man denkt hey das ist
auch verbal ja das hat sich so gefügt
und ich möchte etwas bewirken möchte
keine ahnung ja so aber ist schon schön
dass es sage ich mal noch diese schöne
bedeutung hat weil ich finde in zeiten
wie diesen in zeiten in denen wir leben
sollten sie sich menschen auf jeden fall
an gott wird also das heißt das kind
jetzt ich will das nicht
fundamentalistisch ausdrücken aber man
sollte auf jeden fall
sich gedanken über sich selbst machen
und mit sich selbst im reinen sein und
ich denke der ein guter weg dafür um
nächstenliebe zu erfahren dass auf jeden
fall einen weg zu gott ist meine
persönliche meinung egal aus welcher
religion man stammt wie man das
interpretiert und wie man das aus legt
darüber kann ich kein urteil fällen ich
fühle mich persönlich finde dass der
islam sowohl als auch der christentum
eigentlich nächstenliebe glorifiziert
und die leute haben das nur ein bisschen
und nicht alle aber viele scheinen das
zu vergessen dass wir eigentlich sehr
nahe beieinander sind unsere religion
und eigentlich sehr nahe brüder sind
sind die wurzel die wir haben die
gleichen wurzeln richtig jesus ist ja
auch in die ehe so dass im islam ist
sein prophet glaube ja es sind also auf
jeden fall vorgänger ja ja also da ist
das ist schon eng verknüpft
und vivi wie intensiv beeinflusst sich
das glaube es bremst den oder ist es
etwas was ich sage mal im gedanken
mitschwingt in meinem herzen es ist
soweit ist ausleben kann lebens aus und
man darf das jetzt nicht so
also sage ich mal als pauschalisieren im
sinne von
also wenn ich nach dem islam leben würde
wenn ich kein guter moslem weil ich
viele dinge nicht tue die ein guter
moslem oder bzw ein ehrlicher moslem der
den islam volk tue ich bete ich schaffe
es nicht fünf am tag zu beten dass es
schon peinlich dass sich das eigentlich
sage ich schaffe es nicht weil ich für
viele andere dinge zeit habe dafür aber
nicht vielleicht liegt aber einen
lebensrhythmus aber ich denke ich werde
auch irgendwann dazu kommen alle
pflichten nachzugehen und den weg ins
paradies wie jeder mensch egal aus
welcher religion er stammt zu erleben
aber das ist schon dein ziel dessen ziel
es dann in die hölle zu fahren also da
kannst du mir auch keiner religion
jemanden zeigen wir gerne in die hölle
fährt aufsetzen christus ob es ein
moslem ist ob es im buddhismus der
wahrscheinlich an energie globe oder wie
ich kann mich ich weiß nicht so genau
aber keiner will das schlechte von dem
erleben was einem vorgang mit jeder will
das gute leben der mensch ist ja auch
daran gebunden ein selbsterhaltung since
ding zu haben also daher ist es ja
selbst jemand der altist möchte nicht
geben auch wenn man das oft so
wahrscheinlich denkt so es gibt
natürlich vereinzelte fälle wo man sagt
okay da sind so depressiv der versucht
sich das leben zu nehmen das sind ein
anderes schicksal aber um das mal
allgemein auszudrücken denke ich der
mensch möchte doch von sich aus auf
jeden fall ins paradies natürlich also
ich denke das ist es egal wie sie
aussehen ob wir gelb sind lila schwarz
weiß grün spielt für mich keine rolle
wenn du gut zu mir bist bin ich gut zu
dir ja ich sagen soll der katholik hat
einfach wer muss nicht mal beten am tag
der braucht gar nichts zu tun er braucht
nur am ende alles weich touristen
vergeben und dann kann er
das ist dann wir euch wahrscheinlich so
ob du dann im himmel kommen
wo es steht es geschrieben also ich weiß
das ist ich will eigentlich ungerecht
ist es einfach
ein sehr ein sehr komplexes thema sag
ich mal ein sehr sehr sehr großes thema
wo ich persönlich sage ich mutmaße mir
beziehungsweise ich fühle mich dazu
nicht berufen das ist komplett
auszupacken und zu sagen ich weiß worum
es geht ich habe die weisheit mit
löffeln gefressen
ich weiß auf jeden fall nicht ich hoffe
nur auf das gute und versuche ein guter
mensch zu sein und meine pflichten zu
erfüllen willst du demütig inwiefern ist
das das richtige wort also demütig im
sinne von respekt eben vor der schöpfung
vor gott vor anderen menschen ja
definitiv also ich bin jetzt kein muss
ich auch ehrlich gestehen ich möchte
jetzt ja auch kein moralapostel
raushängen lassen ich bin kein
umweltaktivist der richtigen wälder
rennt und sagt ich beschütze jeden pilz
draußen baum wächst oder aus dem grün
wächst das wahrscheinlich jetzt radikal
klingen aber ich respektiere mein
gegenüber ich respektiere das was
entsteht ich respektiere leben in jeder
form so von daher denke ich dass ich
schon demütig bin okay dann bin ich mal
gespannt
wie sich das auf deinen nächsten alben
auswirkt da ist ja doch wahrscheinlich
war das jetzt motivation weiterzumachen
also auf jeden fall die motivation ist
gerade sehr groß ich habe auch auf der
tour bevor die tour los geht haben wir
noch eine riesige überraschung für die
leute da darf ich noch nicht zu viel
verraten aber ich sag mal so es gibt auf
jeden fall wieder was auf die ohren und
da waren 1 12 gäste bei mir die den
flieger nehmen mussten und das wird
alles noch vor der tür stehen und die
leute sollten augen und ohren offen
halten okay wir sind gespannt auf jeden
fall danke danke dir